adele seemingly shuts down rumors
surrounding her relationship with rich
paul and her postponed vegas residency
ain't got your love anymore
check out the piccadile shared on
tuesday smiling ear to ear in the
caption she announces she's returning to
the stage the grammy winner reveals
she's not only performing at the
upcoming brit awards but she's also
making an appearance on the graham
norton show but it's the last line of
her message that fans are focused on
quote oh and rich sends his love
of course adele's referring to her
boyfriend rich paul after months of
romance rumors the grammy winner
confirmed their relationship during her
sit-down interview with oprah in
november and many fans speculate her
latest single oh my god is about the
sport's age
[Music]
but back to that caption last month
rumors started swirling that drama in
adele and rich's relationship was the
reason behind postponing her vegas
residency weekends with adele you'll
remember she shared this emotional video
hi um um listen
i'm so sorry but um
[Music]
my show ain't ready
and
i can't give you what i have right now
um
and i'm gutted i'm gutted and i'm sorry
it's the last minute we've been awake
for over 30 hours now trying to figure
out and
but there's no trouble in paradise
thanks to adele's cheeky message putting
those rumors to rest
[Music]
instead the singer says many other
factors led to the last minute show
cancellation including the ongoing covet
19 pandemic we've tried absolutely
everything that we can
to put it together in time
and for it to be good enough for you but
we've been absolutely destroyed by
delivery delays and covet half my crew
half my team are down with kobe they
still are
and it's been impossible to finish the
show
but adele loves her fans and did her
best to make up for it by surprising a
few lucky ones with facetime calls and
one thing's for sure expect the singer
show to be big vegas big adele's going
to put on a show i'm sure it's going to
be a great show
and she will redeem herself they've got
to sort this out because adele is a cash
cow and they they know that if if this
relationship falls through if the
residency doesn't happen it's millions
and millions of dollars they're
potentially losing so they really have
to they have to accommodate her needs
and requests
[Music]